ich bin im aufklärungsbataillon drei
mistelbach in niederösterreich tc soldat
und sitzt auf unseren usa anbieten wird
[Musik]
hauptsächlich die wochenstation und
beobachte das umfeld mit der kamera
[Musik]
es ist unser auftrag ein lagebild zu
schaffen
die formationen bei tag oder bei nacht
zu sammeln und wir führen dass bis zu
einem gewissen punkt motorisierte
fahrzeuge durch umso näher wir unseren
aufgaben ins ziel kommen bewegen wir uns
dann sozusagen zu fuß
ich bin im ordnungs button 31 und bin
dort gruppen fordern einmal für uns
super zurzeit betraut und einer von
wenigen soldaten die mit der drohne in
österreich unterwegs sind
[Musik]
das besondere an dieser drohne ist das
hier mit einer mobilen tanner
ausgestattet sind das heißt wir können
die drohne staaten und können dann mit
dem fahrzeug die drohne begleiten umso
längere distanzen zu gewährleisten wir
arbeiten auch natürlich viel mit anderen
batterien zusammen
und natürlich auch streiten